how are you Tom agree on all of this we
got a very excited Jon Gruden last night
too didn't we
well I mean look it was interesting to
see Woodson and Brady back on the same
football field on the same weekend
Vinatieri kicked in the snow Tom I saw
your tweet last night that's how I
responded that was exactly that's
another precise point by you but yeah I
think that when you look at what
happened last night that is the perfect
recipe for conclusion jumping and I
think that what Miami did to the
Patriots two weeks prior at Gillette
where they got a sperm they knocked him
around they put him on the ground even
though they lost by 18 points
I really think Brady entered the game
saying look I'm not gonna have a lot of
time to set my feet and you saw
uncharacteristic and accuracy and
without Gronkowski and the Dolphins
saying you know what we're just gonna
get up in people's faces and we're gonna
bring extra people we're gonna take our
chances they were able to profit from
that rich okay so what do you take out
of this that does actually X's and O's
moving on down the line
cause you concerned with what you saw
from last night it's just that I think
it's what we expected but what we got
weld into a sense of hey they're
indomitable again they're very very very
close in terms of personnel to being
rendered not ordinary but beatable you
know you take Rob Gronkowski out
offensively and yes they played earlier
this season without them but you have a
team who came in at home and had a good
scheme and got pressure on Brady and
does knock them around and you take
somebody out it's going to be an issue
and then defensively we're not talking
about all pros in Kyle van Noy and Trey
flowers but you take them out couple
that with Dante Hightower not being
there and you have two rookies in
Dietrich's wise and Adam Butler playing
your meaningful snaps upfront and guys
like Eric we were just on the bills
practice squad there is a tipping point
for New England so I think it shows more
than anything less than the X's and O's
this is a great round Borgess line it's
the jimmies and Joe's
Tom Curren from NBC Sports Boston
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show I
mean look if if gates drew up what he
drew up last night with Cutler and
Landry and Drake the idea that Big Ben
Brown and Bell aren't going to be a
major problem for New England next week
it's it's it's staring you right in the
face Tom what changes between last night
in the short week for a huge game Sunday
afternoon on CBS what do you think it's
a bunch of formations to ride man when I
do a show together and he talks about it
a lot the Patriots have problems with
the bunch formations when guys get all
jammed up together and then they take
off in different directions and that is
something that the Antonio Brown
flourishes in those crossing really at
the first level as opposed to the
downfield stuff the Patriots will take
away the downfield stuff but what they
have to be is concerned about is
anything with Antonio Brown is that
crossing stuff and getting him on the
ground with Logan Ryan last year in the
patriots defensive secondary one of the
best tacklers in the league at the
cornerback position they really limited
the entire Steelers offense at Le'Veon
brah Le'Veon Bell was cliffy and bail
was less than a hundred percent in that
game and actually left early but
martavis Bryant Antonio Brown Le'Veon
Bell and we'll see what kind of
condition Bell is in this week it's
going to be it's going to be a serious
challenge but I I would shock a lot of
it up to the players that were not on
the field to nuke for New England and
just an outstanding game play enriched
by gays I think case is an excellent
coach and people overlook the fact the
coupler might be the the leading guy in
terms of not someone who'd want to
follow into great battle but he is a
very very good thrower so will van Noy
be back do you think we're just first
blush Tuesday will they be full
complement as best they can be in yeah
no I would think so he got the week off
and he missed a fair amount of the
previous game it was a cast that he
reactivated he wasn't really close this
week straight straight line out of the
game didn't make the trip so there'll be
some there'll be some question as to
what what happens with him but I think
that's important but you know and that's
again the thing
- Landon Roberts and marquise flowers or
at the linebacker level for New England
and that's not the way they came into
the season planning it nor is that going
to be what Pittsburgh is coming into the
season planning either every team is
dealing with plenty of different things
but it's Oh
prior to this morning rich I think
people say well you know Steelers are a
fraudulent ten and two or eleven and two
in the Patriots are going to come from
around I think the conversation has
changed drastically so last one for you
Thomas Brady obviously everybody's
banged up he's a 40-year old guy - what
are the concerns there for the final
three weeks in the season then obviously
saddling up for what they hope is
another deep run into the playoffs he's
taken practices off in the middle of the
week each of the last two weeks he took
two off last week because they had a
longer week I would expect to see the
same thing I would expect to see the
exact same thing from Steelers defensive
coordinator keeps poplar we talked about
we're gonna play man we're gonna press
and we're gonna try and get home with
four which is something that they
haven't done in the past so Brady should
expect another ration of abuse and now
what are you hearing about McDaniel Josh
and maybe pressure would you know what
the Giants knocking on the door etcetera
etcetera Tom what are you hearing about
this you know what I think that it's
more likely this year than prior years
that Josh might take an opportunity to
go elsewhere it's just a feeling that
I've gotten over uh over the last you
know a couple of months I mean he's
taken a pass on a lot of different
places including San Francisco including
that now being a place where Jimmy
Garoppolo is and there's gonna be a
level of him saying whoa whoa whoa that
would uh that would have been a good
spot for me so I wouldn't be surprised
if if this would be a year where the
coordinators go elsewhere and I think
that's a huge key to this annual success
that they've had - rich alright before I
let you go what are what are your
compatriots around town thinking about
the Stanton trade holy crap not that
happy not that happy what a lot of human
cry about with a you know on this guy
you're not and CF Dombrowski is trying
to put the two
back of the tube on that what we's what
is he saying what is he saying we're the
you know we were in on it we were in on
it we wanted a big bet we tried but what
they often do is you know is they make
these knee-jerk ridiculous decisions in
the wake of these things to try and
recoup you know but the same goodwill
and there's a new official beer at
Fenway this year they announced that
today yes what is it Sam Adams I heard
about that right I just saw it beer and
I said this is classic red sauce okay
very good
Tom thanks leek all appreciate it you'd
be well we'll check them along you gotta
let Tom Curren of NBC Sports Boston so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience